i'm tony robles and this is 15 levels of
pool
all the shots and techniques and
fundamentals that we're learning today
are applicable to most games in pool but
we're going to be focusing on the game
of 8 ball today level 1
basic fundamentals in order to master
the game you must have a solid
foundation and that's the bridge the
stance and the stroke the v bridge or
open hand bridge is what is used for
about 60 to 70 of the shots on the pool
table you form a fist take your thumb
attach it to the knuckle spread the
fingers so that you create like a letter
v and that's going to help support the
cue stick going back and forth nice and
smoothly whereas a closed hand bridge
your fingers are nice and loose you
don't want to keep them too tight then
the cue stick is going to rub on your
fingers when you're trying to stroke the
cue stick back and forth the stance is
making sure that you line up your body
with each and every shot
a stroke is like a throwing motion in
the game of pull but the most important
aspect of it is to make sure that you
always come back nice and slowly pause
for a second or two before you decide to
accelerate as you're going forward best
way to confirm that your fundamentals
are intact is to practice a drill called
the center ball drill so you're
basically striking the cue ball dead
center and making sure it goes in a
direct line to the cushion and then in
the straight line back to the tip once
you have your fundamentals down it's
time to take it to the next level level
two aiming the cue ball using the ghost
ball method the way the ghost ball
method works is you want to line two
balls frozen together in a direct line
to the center of the pocket then you get
down on your shot and you line up the
center of the cue ball to the center of
the ball that represents the ghost ball
the cue ball will strike the object ball
where the ghost ball was lined up once
you've mastered the ghost ball method
you'll gain a lot more confidence and
start pocketing balls more consistently
[Music]
level three controlling the cue ball
there are three ways to control the cue
ball the follow shot
the draw shot
and the stop shot
the follow shot is when the cue ball
strikes the object ball and follows it
after contact after striking the cue
ball above the equator it gives it what
we call instant forward momentum which
allows the cue ball to continue to roll
forward after contact a draw shot is
when the cue ball comes back towards you
after striking the object ball in order
to achieve the draw shot you must strike
the cue ball way below the equator in
order to give it back spin so that after
contact the cue ball will draw right
towards you a stop shot is when you
strike the cue ball send it to the
object ball and have the cue ball come
to a complete stop in other words it has
no forward momentum or no backspin
you're going to strike the cue ball
anywhere from the equator to as low as
you can go and what happens is in order
to achieve what we call the slide effect
you must strike it so that the cue ball
starts with backspin once that cue ball
runs out of backspin it starts to slide
for a very short period of time before
it starts to pick up forward momentum
it's at the point that the cue ball is
sliding that you must contact the ball
in order to achieve a stop shot
understanding how to master the stop
shot is all intuition and experience as
well as a lot of practice but if you're
trying to shoot a stop shot
and the cue ball draws back a bit
that means you either hit it too low or
you hit it too hard if it goes forward
that means you hit it too high or you
hit it too soft the cue ball always
tells you the truth and never tells you
a lie let's see how these shots would
work in a real game situation
level four basic positional play
positional play is planning where your
cue ball will end up after executing a
shot the way i play position is i always
plan three shots ahead we're going to
use the shots that we just learned the
draw
this stop
and the follow shot
and as you can see here we are now in
perfect position for the eight ball
level 5 the tangent or 90 degree angle
line you're not always going to have a
straight shot however if you need to cut
the ball in things work out differently
if you're cutting the ball with stop
shot speed the cue ball will not stop it
will follow a 90 degree angle you can
also change the angle coming off the
object ball by using a follow
or a draw shot
a follow shot will go in front of the
tangent line
whereas a draw shot will come behind the
tangent line
level six the carom shot a cam shot is
used when you're coming off a ball that
doesn't have access to a pocket and you
want to come off that ball and use it
almost kind of like a cushion to bounce
the cue ball off of it in order to
pocket another ball in this shot here
the 14 doesn't have a clear shot to a
pocket and neither does a 9 ball so i'm
going to send the cue ball off the 14 to
the 9 ball in the corner pocket
level 7 combination shots a combination
shot is when you hit the cue ball to an
object ball in an attempt to pocket a
second ball the simple version is where
you have a straight combination shot
you're striking the center of the cue
ball to the center of the first object
ball to the center of the second object
ball to the center of the pocket but
rarely are you going to have that
perfect of a combination shot in the
game the ghost ball method can also be
used to shoot more complex combination
shots it's the same technique but
instead of one ghost ball we now have
two it may seem simple but seeing two
ghost balls as opposed to one is a skill
that comes with time and experience and
lots of practice now there's a few more
advance shots that i want to talk about
level eight the kick shot a kick shot is
basically a follow shot that comes off
the rail to understand how a kickshot
works it's basically same angle in
and say mangle out and that means that
the angle that the cue ball hits a rail
will be the angle that comes off the
rail so for one rail kickshots we use a
diamond system the white dots that they
have on the pool table that we use as a
guide to give us a better idea of how to
achieve a certain angle that we're
looking for any time you shoot let's say
a kick shot and the object ball is by
the pocket that is considered zero and
then every diamond that we go above that
we do it in increments of 10. corner
pocket to the first diamond that would
be 10 the second diamond 20
the third diamond 30 and the fourth
diamond which is the side pocket 40. so
what you do is you divide it by two and
that will give you a true same angle in
and same angle out so half of 40 is 20.
so all you have to do is go to the
opposite ray on the opposite side of the
table and send the cue ball towards 20.
common mistakes with kick shots is when
a player either strikes the cue ball too
hard or they accidentally add sidespin
to the cue ball if you do use sidespin
you will not get that same angle in the
same angle out instead you get a
completely different angle whether it's
longer or shorter level 9 the bank shot
a bank shot is when you send the cue
ball to an object ball and the object
ball comes off the cushion towards the
pocket it's basically the same angle in
an angle out so when a bank shot is
struck with too much speed it comes
short of the mark struck too soft it
actually lengthens the angle a bit it's
very easy to mess up the speed if you
are unfamiliar with different types of
speed in the game of pull
level 10 defensive shots you're not
always going to have a clear shot in the
game of pull when that happens you're
going to have to learn how to shoot
defensive shots the most basic defensive
shot and pull is when you strike the cue
ball into an object ball while trying to
hide the cue ball and leave your
opponent a very bad shot there are many
types of defensive shots but we're not
going to get into those today
level 11 side spin all the shots that
we've discussed to this point have been
struck on the cue ball on this vertical
axis right here up and down now we're
going to talk about the horizontal axis
of the cue ball which is called side
spin with a kick shot the cue ball
basically comes same angle in and same
angle out off a rail but when we applied
side spin things work differently it
actually widens the angle coming off the
rail or shortens it depending on which
side you hit some of the common mistakes
people make is they end up either
hitting it with not enough side spin or
too much side spin so i recommend going
in half tip increments to the left and
to the right so that way you familiarize
yourself with how much does it affect
the angle coming off the rail with a
little bit of side spin versus a lot of
side spin
level 12 mass a shot a mass a shot is an
extreme curved shot that is shot with
almost a 90 degree angled q when you
strike the cue ball at a 90 degree it
actually causes a cue ball to go around
almost like a u-turn like i like to use
a mass a shot or a curved shot whenever
there's a ball in front of the pocket
and i have an interfering ball that's
blocking me or preventing me from
hitting the ball directly this shot
requires a lot of confidence but with
practice comes confidence so you should
always start off with just a slight bit
elevation see how much you can curb it
from there while trying to maintain a
lot of spin on the cue ball whether
you're hitting it on the right hand side
or the left hand side and as you start
getting familiar with how much a ball is
curving you start elevating the cue
stick a little more a little more until
you are finally able to get a full-blown
mass sail curve shot around the object
ball level 13 the jump shot it's a
misconception that a jump shot is when
you scoop underneath the cue ball when
in fact that is considered a file in the
game of pool a real jump shot requires
you to come at an angle it sends all the
momentum to the bed of the table which
bounces it over the object ball and
speed is very crucial because if you
strike it too hard you always run the
risk of either jumping the cue ball off
the table or both balls off the table
now that we've covered a long list of
shots we are ready to play a game
level 14 the break the goal of the break
is to give yourself the best chance to
run the table the ideal break is when
you send the cue ball in a direct line
to the lead ball this sends the momentum
of the cue ball into the rack spreading
the balls across the table this will
give you the most options for the first
shot after the break there are two ways
to learn how to break first you must
learn how to break with just your arm no
body movement whatsoever until you learn
how to get an accurate dead square hit
on the head ball once you've done that
then you're going to learn how to throw
your body forward with your arm to get
more power once you've mastered the
momentum of throwing your body into the
brake you have the ability to hit it
much harder and increase the chances of
pocketing a ball on the brake
now let's play
level 15 advanced position play when i
run the table most times i end up using
the techniques that we discussed today
whether it's a draw shot a cam shot a
bang shot
nine degree angle shot all these shots
are tools that need to be mastered in
order to run out the table consistently
whenever i assess a table i always look
for a pattern that is going to minimize
the movement of the cue ball as much as
possible by thinking backwards i first
start looking at the eight and pick a
ball that i think will be the best
candidate to get me to the eight at the
end of the rack and once i figured out
that shot i pick another ball that would
be the best candidate to get me to the
shot before the eight ball and so forth
so
[Music]
we've covered a lot of shots and
techniques today but there's always more
to learn every game is different and
will require different shots and
techniques no two games of pool are
played the same way with the knowledge
that we covered today you should be well
prepared to win thank you for watching
and i hope this improves your game